the push to vaccinate students against
covert is moving to after-school
activities in cities like los angeles
chicago new york and washington d.c los
angeles students involved in sports and
extracurricular programs face a deadline
to get fully vaccinated by the end of
the month lilia luciano is at garfield
high school in east l.a lilia good
morning
good morning to you nate many of the
2400 students that attend garfield high
school know firsthand the devastation
that kovit can bring this predominantly
latino community was one of the hardest
hit here in los angeles and that's one
of the reasons why the entire football
team was fully vaccinated ahead weeks
ahead of the schedule well that and of
course they didn't want to miss out on
the game
the biggest battle the garfield high
school bulldogs are facing this season
isn't just on the field
[Applause]
we came out here initially it was
instead of offering them water we were
all freedom sanitizer as they were
coming off the field the east los
angeles school like others in the
district is determined to stop the
spread of covet 19 even if that means
pulling unvaccinated teens from their
favorite sport or after school activity
depending on the type of activity
obviously they're in school a little bit
longer they're around each other in
closer proximity principal andres favela
says he's already seen a decrease in
positive cases among students since the
school district announced its vaccine
mandate i'm sure some parents will say
it's up to us to decide when to
vaccinate our kids not to the school we
definitely understand that perspective
we're not forcing this on on anybody you
know we feel
as a district that's in line with the
state and uh you know federal government
that vaccination is the clear path to
returning to school safely
back to normal but not everyone was
convinced at first people were saying
they had like other health issues with
it
it wasn't safe for them quarterback
jason vargas says he and his family had
their doubts so we weren't sure and we
kind of waited um waited last minute and
i had to get it
because i wanted to continue my football
season and i wanted to keep everybody
safe do you get calls from the parents
concerned hesitant what kinds of things
were you hearing you know we did hear
some things from some parents that were
concerned but we assured them of the
science and one thing that i always use
as an example i said you know what i
wouldn't be doing it if i didn't think
it was safe according to the cdc
unvaccinated adolescents are 10 times
more likely to be hospitalized with
covet 19 compared to those who have
gotten the shots
so for christian and monica ramos who
have two boys on the football team the
mandate makes just as much sense
as a helmet and pads what do you think
it does for athletes to be the first
ones to get that mandate it sets an
example
because if high school kids can do it
adults can do it i don't see why not
the principal says about 30 percent of
the student population still need to be
vaccinated by that january 10th deadline
if they don't and that's regardless of
whether or not they're participating in
extracurriculars if they don't and they
don't have a valid exemption like a
medical reason
officials from the district say they
cannot be admitted into campus and
they'll be referred to an independent
study program riga
lilia thank you